[Music]
it's a beautiful day to be alive
Thursday February 9th today the devil
was buried at sea if you look at my eyes
you could tell it's been a rough [__]
week two nights who said when we [__]
jujitsu [__] flying through the air I
gotta go to acupuncture tank clean up my
adrenals my liver my gallbladder it's
over I'm on the straight hair after this
no more [__] sugar cubes for me let
me tell you something last night I can't
see without my glasses I must have put a
couple drops on that [__] shoe cube
because that was off and running Jack I
was saying things I haven't seen in
years it's always good to get that type
of stuff out of your way once or twice a
year and move on with your life and now
we're ready cause it's Thursday you got
the world by the balls
your uncle Joey's here that's it and
that's that why we [__] talking this
time to Sparky
[Applause]
this has taken down the effects of the
poorly saya he's at home with [__]
ice bags on his head and [__] II don't
know what doing is to get into mop
it's [__] trembling listen more in
training or in training I know you guys
think I'm [__] nuts or whether I'm
just trying to have a good time man
listen I'm 54 next week I'm just trying
to have a good time you try you try to
just have a good time I don't have a
good time in California with these
[__] people that little office with
Lee and Dean tell where Jo or somebody
comes to visit Ralphie that's my [__]
world that's why I do my best [__]
work guys so thank you very much for
supporting about this but enough with
the [__] chitchat let's smoke a
little reefer I can't send you out there
into the real [__] world you know if
you're not tuned up and ready to go we
got Danny Brown coming on the podcast we
got George Mars about coming on the
podcast we got my man Tom Rhodes this
week coming on the podcast more than a
month strong for you [__]
enough with the acid or whatever but
what you need to worry about is today
today who's gonna suck your [__] dead
dick polls today who's gonna [__]
whose lunch box are you taking today
that's the [__] question of the ages
right there are you gonna go out today
and end up like you do every day
tomorrow be a better day let's see what
tomorrow brings tomorrow don't bring
dick it's what you show up with
[__]
it's Thursday it's February [__]
night who's dick
they'll call me in three weeks man got
three [__] weeks you need a job today
you need to get up today and watch that
[__] [__] and powder that nutsack
and get out there with [__]
confidence you understand me but you're
the captain curtly your [__]
enterprise this weeds already hit me
tomorrow ain't gonna bring you the
action is on the table today let me tell
you what I'm doing I'm gonna smoke a
little bit of me eat a little bit more
my wife a little something I already had
a protein shake
I shoot down a Marina del Rey little
acupuncture i'ma come home I got a four
o'clock phone call with Lois Gomez and
my man Michael Bisping and then tonight
I got a spot at the Laugh Factory we had
at the [__] Comedy Store I'm also
gonna try to hit 6:30 jujitsu to keep my
numbers up it's a beginner class but
look at me
I've been a beginner all my [__] life
it's when you take your [__] star
that things go down the tubes your butt
get it jack you just stuck with it and
you kept going I'm just a beginner
that's stuck with it can you believe
that [__] that's how simple this [__]
life is everybody makes a big deal about
how it was gonna take me to be 10 years
all I can't do that bro you'd be
surprised how fast 10 years goes and you
know what those 10 years are gonna go by
and you're still gonna be in the same
place you were before stick to it get in
there keep showing up put your blinders
on put some [__] my own airs on your
dick and going every time do the best
you can do that's it that's it listen I
know I put my pants on one leg at a time
I smoked dope like a [__] I
never claimed to be nothing all I'm a
body's heart and boss that's it every
day you gotta keep getting in there brah
Holly doll a pool table I do that's what
you need to do you don't say
and that's it I'm feeling good I'm
optimistic we got some good [__] happen
and I'm happy you [__] that I'm
coming to Buffalo and my man Joe Rogan
so Canada get on alert [__] well
lighten that room I'm [__] fire that
night you understand me
and beside that uncle Joey loves you
[__] don't forget tomorrow
socially unacceptable comes out on CD on
iTunes do me the [__] favor all right
you know I don't ask you for nothing do
me the [__] thing
oh I love smoking [__] with you
people
it's a beautiful way to start a Thursday
let's number Jerry [__] that you know
spiritually mentally all you got to do
when you think about me is balls okay
that's it what would Joey the ball
straight up ie golly Bob
[__] up I still got fumes from the a
Celeste ID you know we must say that my
[__] 1500 milligrams last met awesome
a team see it just wasn't the [__]
Sid LaRue we don't [__] around people
you understand me the church the Voodoo
Lounge it's over in there but guess what
I gotta take two steps to the rear and
get out of here I gotta get the Marina
del Rey
I'm gonna cut myself - gonna cut me move
the blood around then she's gonna pull a
thousand [__] needles in me and my
nutsack my feet everything to get the
circulation going to get this [__]
acid I'm gonna drink water all day like
a [__] and that's it and that's
that you understand me
it's okay for you play from time to time
as long as the next day you drain out
all the [__] fluids and you're ready
to go if you're stuck in an airport suck
my dick you should have watched the news
it's gonna snow for [__] the next
[__] 18 [__] days you're in no
danger had a better chance we get man a
[__] bicycle and getting out into
that Airport
so come see us our [__] don't
forget I don't socially I'll accept you
know what who the [__] mind I smoked
another book I'm glad I'm gonna sit here
with one leg [__] around with you beep
what's Thursday you gotta go out [__]
swingin all right it's like 2 o'clock
for some places 4 o'clock do some places
I don't give a [__] the result is the
same we all get to see the devil just at
different times
hey you though I feel good as long as
you guys are good and your goals are
intact and you're focused and you're
ready to dig in there it's open you know
I love you [__] have a great
day
I'll see you [__] come on row
same bat-time same bat-channel
and don't show up but I know reefer cuz
I've stabbed me in the [__] eye I've
trumped wheat you some [__]
stay black [__] up with Joey
loves you